[Music]
he's messaging me so many times just the
contest's I was trying to do a wake up
scene this morning then Casey who is
just so impatient he sent me about a
hundred hurry up hurry up messages even
though I think I'm still ready
today's a big day today is my 30th
birthday which when saying feels kind of
melancholic that's too far like I'm
stoked and grateful in order to be alive
but I just don't feel like a video or a
dot so my friend Casey the one who was
messaging me like a madman it's just a
mentor of mine and has lived three spins
he's waiting outside for me right now to
take me on some sort of a day mission
but I'm really only interested in asking
him one question
[Music]
what does it mean it's anything I think
30 is like 33 year when you become an
adult like your 20s you're still kind of
your parents responsibility you're still
kind of like a kid big and that also
means you should have a you should have
a plan by 30 like you you spend your 20s
wandering and drifting but by 30 you
should understand what the trajectory is
no one else really cares about your
problems after 30 because you're an
adult I never thought I'd make it to 30
so much so that I tap 230 on my arm I
know I mentioned it's my birthday and
all but it's as I was saying at the same
time I I do feel sad and I didn't
exactly why that is yet you are never
gonna be in your 20s ever again for the
rest
Oh
[Music]
but in the end I just say being your 20s
is not better than being your 30s just
like being your thirties it's probably
not better than being your 40 it's just
different but
[Music]
Kasey's honest an insightful outlook
towards life help me to conclude the
answer to my question as this I'll start
at the beginning
I guess the feeling of melancholy came
from the idea of who I think I'm
supposed to be a thing based on
comparing myself to others which is
[ __ ] each and every person is in the
only times over at the age of thirty
they are self-made billionaires or
inventors changing the world and then
there are some who haven't even figured
out what it is they want to do with
their lives and who may become the next
greatest musician restaurant owner and
to find happiness in what's most
important like for family and just being
personally content looking back I need
to stop living so fast and you do
cherish the moments like this with my
friends more often and and to stop
comparing myself to what others have
done steady to me now marks nothing but
a number to be proud a number to
celebrate with my friends with my family
and to realize that I'm never gonna be
old enough to stop learning if I could
leave you with one piece of advice if
you want to take my advice it's to live
in your time zone to be a good person I
mean while we all make mistakes but for
the most part be a good person because
well you're never gonna get today back
ever
wait that seems like a bleak way in this
you are you and that's awesome despite
your age now go make memories and
talking about memories I've been
rummaging through some of my old things
well unlock down in quarantine and came
across this old box which has my very
first ever video camera in it I made all
my first movie
this one dates the whole way back to
2003 and what's super exciting is I've
compiled all of this knowledge that I've
gained over the years into my second
ever Skillshare class who also the
sponsors of this week's video I
absolutely loved working with Skillshare
because it gives me the ability to take
what I've learned and to put it into a
simple structured class format and if
you don't know what Skillshare is
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creative and curious
people where millions of people get the
knowledge they need to take the next
step from beginning the whole way into
masters I've learned incredible things
in classes on Skillshare from
photography animation sound design and
video production and I'm looking forward
to even more and so is Joey what so you
know who's chasing birds Joe's going
crazy during lockdown the last one I got
into was video on a budget
prepare your shoot without breaking the
bank by Christopher Rhodes because it
deals with how to recreate more
expensive setups when you don't have the
budget early on then as I mentioned big
news my second ever class is live on
Skillshare it's called filmmaking for
all tell your story through videos it's
also just become a start pick on the
Skillshare website which is a pretty big
deal
and I'd love you to check it out so much
so that the first 500 of my subscribers
to click on the link below get two
months free Premium Membership on
Skillshare so link over and watch my
class other than that please subscribe
to my channel it's just a simple click
of a button as well as I'll also link it
below and then don't forget to turn your
post notifications bar on lastly don't
forget your awesome brew and I'll see
you next week
[Music]